let's get back to the phones for the
last time in 2019 at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty why don't
we go to oh I don't know let's go to our
caller from the three three six area
code who's calling today from three
three six I gave it this is Dylan from
North Carolina hey Dylan what's going on
I'm doing pretty well I was just
thinking long term policy you know with
this whole Cavanaugh situation the
Supreme Court being as it is I'm really
concerned as to what kind of new things
will come down the pipeline and I'm
wondering if maybe Democrats I don't
want to say should give up on some
issues but may be a lost cause I want to
talk about specifically gun control hmm
I'm wondering if the resources we use
and specifically getting assault weapons
bans magazine capacity bands are you
know I see a lot of people in the
community especially the gun community
they want to counteract these laws and
the Second Amendment sanctuary cities
you know I guess my question to you is
is should we not focus more on women's
rights gay rights stuff like that and
whether or not any legislation we get in
I mean what are the chances of it being
able to be held up especially with the
Washington DC ban being overturned no I
think that so a couple things number one
we should be fighting for everything all
the time because they can't stop
everything
first and foremost that's that's the
that's just a reality that we have to
understand number two remember
the Supreme Court does not hear every
case and so a lot of these things take a
very very long time to really be to get
all the way up to the Supreme Court if
the Supreme Court is even going to hear
it particularly if we're able to remove
Donald Trump in 2020 we'll have a
Democratic House even with a Republican
Senate there are still things that can
be done there are things that can be
done at the state level a universal
background checks is one that is less
likely that the Supreme Court would even
choose to get involved in because there
appears to be at least far less
constitutional argument there and so I
reject the idea that we shouldn't be
fighting these things sure we have a
conservative Supreme Court and
depending on what happens in November of
2020 it may become even more
conservative but the Supreme Court is
not going to stop everything it is not
going to hear every case and there is
huge progress that can be made and it's
it is sort of I mean listen it's hard
enough to get stuff done at the state
level and with a divided House and
Senate the idea that we shouldn't even
do it because the Supreme Court might
hear it and reverse it I I don't think
makes sense whatsoever alright I
appreciate your answer alright thank you
so much for the call great great to hear
from you hope to hear from you again